les troupes canadiennes auront réussi à
avancer plus loin en terre ennemie que
n'importe quel autre armée lors du
débarquement de normandie nous soldats
venaient d'entrer dans l'histoire
mais ce soir là ils pleureront la perte
dessus qu'ils ne reverront jamais notre
pays la perte de paires de frères et de
fils qui il ya 75 ans jour pour jour ont
fait le sacrifice de leur vie pour leurs
concitoyens pour les générations futures
pour vous et moi
plus de 5000 canadiens sont tombés sur
les champs de bataille de la normandie
75 ans plus tard nous nous souvenons de
l'ampleur de leur sacrifice nous
souvenons notamment des compagnies de la
première vague et les queens of canada
qui ont subi des pertes énormes dans les
premières heures du jour j
nous nous rappelons leur courage leur
ténacité et leur générosité
les troupes canadiennes auront réussi à
avancer plus loin en terre ennemie que
n'importe quel autre armée lors du
débarquement de normandie nous soldats
venaient d'entrer dans l'histoire
mais ce soir là ils pleureront la perte
dessus qu'ils ne reverront jamais notre
pays la perte de paires de frères et de
fils qui il ya 75 ans jour pour jour ont
fait le sacrifice de leur vie pour leurs
concitoyens pour les générations futures
pour vous et moi plus de 5000 canadiens
sont tombés sur les champs de bataille
de la normandie 75 ans plus tard nous
nous souvenons de l'ampleur de leur
sacrifice nous souvenons notamment des
compagnies de la première vague comme
les élites qui ont subi des pertes
énormes dans les premières heures du
jour j
nous rappelons leur courage leur
ténacité et leur générosité